- [Voiceover] What we're
gonna cover in this video
is the intermediate value theorem.
Which, despite some of this
mathy language you'll see
is one of the more intuitive theorems
possibly the most
intuitive theorem you will
come across in a lot of your
mathematical career.
So first I'll just read it out
and then I'll interpret it and hopefully
we'll all appreciate
that it's pretty obvious.
I'm not going to prove it here.
But, I think the conceptual
underpinning here is
it should be straightforward.
So the theorem tells us
that suppose F is a function
continuous at every point of the interval
the closed interval, so
we're including A and B.
So it's continuous at every
point of the interval A, B.
Let me just draw a couple of examples
of what F could look like just
based on these first lines.
Suppose F is a function
continuous at every point
of the interval A, B.
So let me draw some axes here.
So that's my Y axis.
And this is my X axis.
So, one situation
if this is A.
And this is B.
F is continuous at every
point of the interval
of the closed interval A and B.
So that means it's got
to be for sure defined
at every point.
As well, as to be continuous you have
to defined at every point.
And the limit of the function
that is recorded at that point
should be equal to the value
of the function of that point.
And so the function is
definitely going to be defined
at F of A.
So it's definitely going to have an F of A
right over here.
That's right over here
is F of A.
Maybe F of B is higher.
Although we can look at different cases.
So that would be our F of B.
And they tell us it is
a continuous function.
It is a continuous function.
So if you're trying to
imagine continuous functions
one way to think about it is
if we're continuous over an interval
we take the value of the function at
one point of the interval.
And, if it's continuous
we need to be able to
get to the other, the
value of the function
at the other point of the interval
without picking up our pencil.
So, I can do all sorts of things
and it still has to be a function.
So, I can't do something like that.
But,
as long as I don't pick up my pencil
this is a continuous function.
So, there you go.
If the somehow the graph
I had to pick up my pencil.
If I had to do something like this
oops, I got to pick up my
pencil do something like that,
well that's not continuous anymore.
If I had to do something like this
and oops, pick up my pencil
not continuous anymore.
If I had to do something like
wooo.
Whoa, okay, pick up my
pencil, go down here,
not continuous anymore.
So, this is what a continuous function
that a function that is continuous
over the closed interval A, B looks like.
I can draw some other examples, in fact,
let me do that.
So let me draw
one.
Maybe where F of B is less than
F of A.
So it's my Y axis.
And this is my
X axis.
And once again, A and B don't both
have to be positive,
they can both be negative.
One could be, A could be negative.
B could be positive.
And maybe in this situation.
And F of A and F of B
it could also be a positive or negative.
But let's take a situation where this is
F of A.
So that, right over there,
is F of A.
This right over here
is F of B.
F of B.
And once again we're saying F is a
continuous function.
So I should be able to go from F of A
to F of B
F of B draw a function
without having to pick up my pencil.
So it could do something like this.
Actually I want to make it go vertical.
It could go like this
and then go down.
And then
do something
like that.
So these are both cases
and I could draw an
infinite number of cases
where F is a function
continuous at every point
of the interval.
The closed interval, from A to B.
Now, given that
there's two ways to state the conclusion
for the intermediate value theorem.
You'll see it written in one of these ways
or something close to one of these ways.
And that's why I included both of these.
So one way to say it is, well
if this first statement is true
then F will take on every value
between F of A and F of B
over the interval.
And you see in both of these cases
every interval, sorry, every
every value between F of A
and F of B.
So every value here
is being taken on at some point.
You can pick some value.
You can pick some value,
an arbitrary value
L, right over here.
Oh look.
L happened right over there.
If you pick L
well, L happened right over there.
And actually it also happened there
and it also happened there.
And this second bullet point describes
the intermediate value
theorem more that way.
For any L between the values of F and A
and F of B
there are exists a number C
in the closed interval from A to B
for which F of C equals L.
So there exists at least one C.
So in this case
that would be our C.
Over here, there's potential
there's multiple candidates for C.
That could be a candidate for C.
That could be a C.
So we could say there exists at least
one number.
At least
one number, I'll throw that in there,
at least one number C
in the interval for which this is true.
And, something that might amuse you
for a few minutes is
try to draw a function where this first
statement is true.
But somehow the second statement is
not true.
So, you say, okay, well let's say
let's assume that there's an L
where there isn't a C in the interval.
Let me try and do that.
And I'll draw it big so that
we can really see how obvious
that we have to take on
all of the values between F and A
and F of B is.
So,
let me draw a big axis this time.
So that's my Y axis.
And,
that is my X axis.
And I'll just do the case where
just for simplicity, that is A
and that is B.
And let's say
that this is F of A.
So that is
F of A.
And let's say that this
is F of B.
Little dotted line.
All right.
F of B.
And we assume that we
we have a continuous function here.
So the graph, I could draw it from
F of A to F of B from this point
to this point
without picking up my pencil.
From this coordinate A comma F of A
to this coordinate B comma F of B
without picking up my pencil.
Well, let's assume
that there is some L
that we don't take on.
Let's say there's some
value L right over here.
And,
and we never take on this value.
This continuous function
never takes on this value
as we go from X equaling A to X equal B.
Let's see if I can draw that.
Let's see if I can get
from here
to here
without ever essentially
crossing this dotted line.
Well let's see, I could, wooo,
maybe I would a little bit.
But gee, how am I gonna get there?
Well, without picking up my pencil.
Well,
well, I really need to
cross that line,all right.
Well, there you go.
I found, we took on the value L
and it happened at C
which is in that closed interval.
So once again, I'm not
giving you a proof here.
But hopefully you have a good intuition
that the intermediate value theorem
is kind of common sense.
The key is you're dealing
with a continuous function.
If you make its graph
if you were to draw it between
the coordinates A comma F of A
and B comma F of B
and you don't pick up your pencil,
which would be true of
a continuous function.
Well, it's going to take on every value
between F of A and F of B.